Karry is with us in Amarillo hi Carrie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hello
how are you
better than I deserve what's up okay I
have a question and my husband and I
make about 140 thousand a year we have
very good jobs
five children about six years ago we
bought a business from some family
friends and at that time we didn't have
any debt not even on our home except for
a vehicle in a rental house and when we
went into this business venture we
financed it personally so credit cards
personal loans and we expanded and now
I'm in a situation where we give more to
the business and it gives to us and it's
not our main source of income but it's
becoming a strain because we're having
to pay multiple debt payments so I'm not
sure what to do if I should close the
business but I don't know how to handle
the debt once I do that well it's just
personal debt okay yes yes we find it
much much much credit card debt do you
have quite a bit if you saw my list
right now you would go crazy how I'm
about to go crazy then you're going to
give me your list how much credit card
debt credit card debt is about thirty
thousand okay what's the rest of it
and then the rest we have a total all
together with the thirty thousand four
hundred and ninety nine thousand that is
with four properties in there as well
with mortgages okay how much of
mortgages the mortgages let me see we've
got forty seven eight on one I have
forty one one on one I have thirty
thousand on another and then I'm and
forty three on one so only a hundred and
seventy or so of the 500 is mortgages
what's the rest of it mortgage in that
too yes I do
Oh whatever we are home that's the forty
seven eight which we refund
to purchase the business but we do have
a truck payment in there our truck
that's at 29 and that's the only car
payments that we have but the rest we
did some personal loans and then credit
card to the rest that's right you got a
lot of personal loans in like three
hundred thousand dollars off yes there
are several in there and then there was
one big business it was like a business
loan that we did get towards the end but
that one actually they had it came back
with the settlement on that one for
forty thousand so that would take off
part of that for 99 out of that we one
thing that we did do and I have a
question which was probably not the
right thing we I made the decision to
work with a debt consolidation program
not realizing what that is until we got
involved and it really hurts your credit
and they only pay those that they can at
the time when you're depositing
monthlies know what's going on Beverly
no it did yes so I don't know where to
where to go you need to end that is your
first place did yes one of the
properties what are the properties worth
not counting your home the other three
the other three I have one at it's worth
about seventy one that's and then the
other two rows are about sixty
sixty-five okay alright let's just get
all those sold they're not making you
any money
okay we've had the business for sell for
a year and a half and it hasn't sold
yeah is the but the properties don't
even do the business right it's it's
personal that's just where we run it
yeah I mean that's our business location
property it's a commercial property yeah
but we just finance said our Celsius and
what did you pay for this business we
paid a hundred and eighty thousand
the problem here is i think what and and
the business is retail so our inventory
costs are really high plus we pay
someone to manage it and that's where
most of our expenses go so they're not
overpaid
for the business then yes so how much
are you asking for right now we have the
property for sell for 65 and then I mean
we had the problem we had it at 250 but
we can't really did any offers on that
and so we lowered it to just 64 the
property which is for 7 but we probably
can't get that and then we were going to
negotiate on the business portion with
if someone was interested just because
we can't really get a good feel and
people come in and look at it and then
they don't want to take on this and you
know how much it it takes to do it yeah
well you're gonna you've got all the dad
I mean you're just gonna whatever you
can get out of the business we'll help
you towards the debts all at least you
can get it get away from this thing is
bleeding and you can get rid of your
worries we have very good incomes and I
know that we could do well it's just we
made this business decision and we
financed it the way we did and that was
not the right way so overpay you overpay
and you financed it and you announced it
the wrong way if you were gonna finance
it so yeah you just got a you got a real
big pile stuff to shovel out here yeah I
think that's what you do you know let's
get the thing priced properly let's get
rid of it let's get these other
properties priced properly and let's get
rid of them let's just start cleaning up
and then you'll be left with the residue
which will be a pile of debt and and you
definitely need a $30,000 freaking car
in the middle of all this for sure and
so let's get rid of that I mean let's
just start selling everything in sight
and if it's not bolted down or even if
it is let's sell it and then let's work
our way through from there through
whatever's left over at that point and
as you've done go in and settle some of
these debts occasionally always doing
that in writing and always doing it in a
lump sum and no electronic access to
your checking account but I think you're
gonna get it if I I can't tell from the
numbers they get a little fuzzy in our
discussion but I think you're gonna get
this down to under two hundred thousand
dollars where the debt making 140
that'll take you a little while with us
doable I don't think the full half
million is still laying
especially by the time we clear the
properties the business in the car and
and then then I can start to see my way
through this with your income and that's
what you do so hey sorry you're facing
this but if you need some help more help
on detail stuff as you're working your
way out of it you call me anytime I know
you're scared I've been there too